- All right.
Well, it's no secret.
It's been a rough couple
years for all of us.
And mental health has been
at the top of the list.
It has to be.
But, help doesn't have to
look the same for everyone.
One Brooklyn ray psychotherapist
says her clients,
who are primarily Latina women,
need more than just
traditional talk therapy.
She's all about a hands-on approach
with breath-work, touch,
and ancestral practices.
She's here to tell us about it.
So, everybody give a warm
welcome to Christine.
(audience clapping)
Hi, Christine.
- Thank you.
- So-
- Thank you for having me.
- No, you're than welcome.
Thank you for joining us.
So, explain more about
how you've tailored your
approach for your clients.
- Yeah, so when I first
became a therapist,
I realized that the more
westernized approach
to therapy was a bit
more clinical and direct.
And while that's super
important and necessary,
I also felt that with
our Latino community,
we really crave that
warmth and that touch,
and I wanted to make it
approachable to our community.
And so I incorporated
meditation and breath-work,
and we get to sit together in circle,
and cry together and scream if we need to.
And just really hold each
other as we break open.
And it was through this work
that I decided to create
my book, "I Am Diosa."
And the Diosahood Community,
which is a space where women can come,
and learn about self esteem
and mental health resources.
But, that really do so in a way
that connects to our culture and our root.
- That's amazing.
(audience clapping)
It also sounds like Texas women
that I grew up with as well.
Like, we love that as well.
What you just described is
very relatable to me as well.
- That's great.
- So, you're going to
teach us all one exercise
to relieve stress.
- So-
- Yes.
- Thank you in advance.
And immediately, right?
- Yes. Yes.
- Where have you been?
- Yes.
- Okay, so wait, do y'all wanna join in?
Y'all wanna stand up with
us? Stand on up with us.
All right. All right.
- [Christine] Breath-work-
- [Kelly] There we go.
- Breath-work is a really easy way to just
release stuck energy from the body.
And so if you are pregnant
or if you have a medical condition,
you can just feel the vibes of this.
And instead we're gonna just,
the rest of you can lift
up your hands to the air.
And we're gonna inhale in
and we're gonna exhale out.
Ha! Ha! Ha!
- Ha! Ha!
- Really putting you hands
- Ha! I like it!
- [Christine] Ha! Yes!
- [Kelly] Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha!
- Now think of all the things you wanna
bring into your life.
Love.
(everyone chanting)
Money!
Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha!
- Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha!
- [Christine] Health.
- [Kelly] Ha! Ha! Ha!
- Money. Health. Love. Abundance. Ha!
Now say yes, yes, yes! Say yes to life!
Yes! Yes! Yes! Yes!
- Ha! Ha! Ha! Yes! Yes!
- [Christine] Yes! Yes! Yes!
(Kelly laughing)
Wooo!
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
That last bit I laughed,
'cause it reminded me
of the scene in "When Harry Met Sally,"
(audience laughing)
and that's where my childish brain goes.
But you know, I think there's
something to it as well.
Just physically, like
getting your body to move
and even like-
- That's right.
- getting like that air out like that.
That's nice.
- Yes. And when we can breathe like this,
this is a tool that
you can do by yourself.
So, use it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And remember that we have
the power to create this energy
within ourselves and-
- You're a firecracker.
- be so proud.
- Yeah, I like it. I like it.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much, Christine.
- Thank you. Thank you, mama.
- [Kelly] I'm liking your post right now.
- [Christine] Yes.
- All well, that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show" want to honor
truly unstoppable people
just like you, ma'am,
so they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars to
help out on your endeavor.
All right?
- Thank you!
- [Kelly] No, thank you,
that was fun. I liked that.